least mean squares estimation is
remarkable because it has such a simple
answer the way to come up with estimates
if what you care about is to keep the
mean squared error small the way to come
up with estimates is to just report the
conditional expectation which is going
to be a number once you have obtained
some values of the data or more
abstractly you can think of it as a
random variable if you do not know ahead
of time what data you're going to obtain
because this estimator is so important
it is worth writing down what the
performance of that estimator is so
suppose that you have obtained a
particular measurement a particular
value of the observation then the
resulting mean squared error within that
conditional universe where you have
already obtained that value is just this
quantity it's the mean square of the
error between the variable that you're
trying to estimate and your estimate and
everything gets computed within this
conditional universe now this is a very
familiar quantity however it's the
expected value of a random variable
difference from its mean squared this is
just a variance except that because all
quantities are calculated in a
conditional universe this is the
conditional variance so the conditional
variance is the optimal mean squared
error the mean squared error that you
obtain when you use this particular
estimate and it's the value that you
would report to your boss if you were
asked how good is the estimate that you
are giving me but suppose that you have
not yet obtained a measurement but you
are going to your boss and you're
proposing this particular estimator is
your design what are you going to report
to your boss is the performance of your
design since you have not yet obtained
the value of X X is the random variable
you do not know what the value of this
conditional expectation is going to be
it's a random variable but no matter
what it is this is going to be the error
that you're going to be obtained
and this is the overall value of the
mean squared error so this is the
quantity that you would report to your
boss as your overall mean squared error
the value that you report before
obtaining any specific measurement now
what is this quantity this quantity is
just the average of this quantity up
here averaged over all the possible
values of X and in our more abstract
notation it is just the expectation of
the conditional variance the conditional
variance the abstract conditional
variance is a random variable that takes
this value whenever capital X happens to
be equal to little X and when we average
it over all possible values of X we just
have the expectation of this random
variable let me continue now with a few
more comments on LMS estimation first
something that should be pretty clear at
this point is that LMS estimation is
only relevant to estimation problems
this is because in hypothesis testing
problems we typically care about the
probability of error not the mean
squared error a second important comment
is that in some cases the LMS estimates
and the map estimates turn out to be the
same when is that the case if the
posterior distribution of theta happens
to have a single peak and it is also
symmetric around a certain point so that
the peak also occurs at that particular
point then clearly the peak occurs here
but the conditional expectation is also
that same point because it is the center
of symmetry so in those cases the two
types of estimates or estimators
coincide when does this happen
this happens in one particular important
special case we have seen that in linear
normal models the posterior distribution
is normal and so this is one
is where the map estimate and the LMS
estimates are going to coincide